so we have four different compounds here
and we also have their molar masses and
what I would like you to do is think
about which of these compounds has the
highest highest percentage of sulfur by
mass so pause this video and see if you
can figure that out alright now one way
to approach this is to say for each of
these compounds
so if we say per mole of each compound
of each compound we could figure out how
many grams ios8 what is the mass what is
the mass of sulfur divided by the total
mass of the compound total total mass of
the compound now the mass of sulfur we
can see that for a mole of each of these
compounds you have exactly one mole of
sulfur and all of these formulas you see
exactly one sulfur so in all of these
situations the mass of sulfur is going
to be the same this is going to be the
same same for all compounds it wouldn't
be the same for all compounds if some of
them had two sulfur's or some of them
had three or maybe some of them had none
but all of them have one sulfur so for a
mole of each of these compounds you're
going to have a mole of sulfur and so
they're going to have the same mass of
sulfur we could take out a periodic
table and we could look it up and we
could say oh look the average atomic
mass of sulfur is 30 2.06 and so if I
had a mole of it it would be 32 point oh
six grams so we could put the thirty-two
point oh six grams up here if we like
this would be 32 point zero six grams in
all of these cases because once again if
you have a mole of each of these
compounds are going to have a mole of
sulfur because you only see one sulfur
in these in each of these formulas but
the big picture is is in all of the
cases I'm gonna have the same value in
the numerator so if I want to have the
highest percentage I would want to
minimize the value in the denominator so
I would really want to
which one would have the lowest
denominator or which one would have the
lowest mass for a mole of the molecules
or another way of thinking about it
which of them will have the lowest molar
mass and you could see very clearly that
this compound right over here has the
lower lowest molar mass so we're done
this has the highest percentage of
sulfur by mass because per mole it has
the same mass of sulfur as everything
else but it has the lowest total mass
who's going to have the highest
percentage of sulfur so a quick way to
do it we just looked at the lowest molar
mass you could have gone and take taken
thirty two point zero six and divided by
each of these values and figured out a
percentage but they're not asking us to
figure out the percentage they're saying
which one has the highest percentage and
that would be this second compound right
over there